sure I'll play see guys on the toaster
how's it going welcome to today it's
currently morning time right now and
we're just about to have breakfast
yesterday we went for a really fun trip
to Vegas you guys ever seen the property
brothers on HGTV or if you've ever seen
them on Netflix where I first found them
we shot some super fun videos so I look
forward to showing you guys those in the
near future we also got a few design
tips from them because I'm trying to get
furniture and do a little decorating the
virus because jenna has been such a
really great sister helping me move
things around and watch my dog I'm gonna
make her a really great - breakfast in
bed and we actually just had the new bed
be delivered today here's the bedroom
dilemma the bed doesn't quite match up
with the dresser which kind of is
driving me crazy
there's only one outlet that's able to
be visible so apparently the movers
tried to make it so that this outlet
would be usable what we really need is
this outlet the Zen table is smaller
than this end table so we need to do a
little swap because the bed needs to be
scooted over just a little bit the
biggest bedroom dilemma is this mattress
is a queen mattress and the king
mattress has not come in yet the bed
looks great but it needs to be moved
over a little bit and guess what I can't
do lift heavy things something I can do
is make breakfast good at that I need to
listen to some music while I cook what
should we listen to
my obsession Jenna just just spit out
the data we get a reenactment of what
happened tasted the potato with mmm
might still be frozen but it's warm I
think it's just not good potato
breakfast is sorry
Oh at what point is too much caffeine
too much guess we'll find out I've got a
small bone to pick
I get really fussy when people are in
parking garages and they sit and wait
for like 45 minutes okay maybe like a
couple minutes for people to like park
Pizza Annika how many Danica yeah
they've got a really nice salmon dish
that I'd like
well tonight we have to build some
chairs and finally got the chairs I'll
have to ocean show you the bedroom that
it's test if not right it's a full
process but I think it's coming together
we still have to figure out what carpet
we're going to get and now I need to
find some really strong men to move the
bed for me what was my website that I
was going to start big movement [ __ ] big
strong group of men calm is a really
great company I want to start I just
wanna be like have like a big group I'm
struggling then they can come and do
things for you like move stuff
Allah wants Amin's leave out furniture
building and moving things just weeks
you want to have a blast boy if you're
over the age of whatever the legal
drinking age isn't where you are what
happened today I made eggs and I debated
on playing Pokemon go I edited four
videos then I took a nap and then I'm
here and now I'm not sure I cried the
car on axle
everybody wonder how many times it's
gonna take me to try to get this guy oh
you broke free oh of course you did oh
you ran away of course you did this game
is broken so we basically came down here
I don't even sure why we had we really
did we end up just eating and then left
and now we're gonna go home to build the
chairs I'm so sad those people just drop
that dog they did they drop their dog on
the escalator like what are you doing it
was really sad oh I'm like disturb no
they dropped him where'd you go oh yeah
I'm ready
team Fowler
looks good looks just like the old
chairs those are falling apart
Oh stiff we're going to be making a
cappuccino cooler